also I'm going to say this and then all
of a he's going to call this guy's going
to call and want to get back on here and
yell at me so check it out Aries
Spears you guys already repaired it no
I'm going to I'm going to unpr no this
is true though so at the time they hired
Keegan and Jordan at the same time to
replace
Aries really
yeah okay yeah yeah and so so they were
only use one of them right but Aries was
so [__] and negative and he's not like
he's not Mr like worm no yeah he's going
to come here and [__] yell at me he's
warm now he's great now oh I I think
he's I think he's gone through so that
was just your perception of him no no
he no I could I mean you see it I'm a
always a fan a fan it was always even
when he was being nice it felt
dark anyway so they knew they tried so
Keegan and um Jordan baned together so I
remember one day we were at table read
this actually happened we're at the
table read and um Keegan and Jordan tell
the network can we move the tables cuz
we you know you when you do a table you
read the script right they go we're not
going to read it we're going to do
it and like we were all like oh these
two are going to do something so they we
pulled the tables back and stuff and
they did this they did the full sketch I
forgot what it was but I remember it
crushed and I remember look but every I
would look at them and also then I would
look at
Aries and I would look at them and I
would look at Aries why are you smiling
wait because I'm like you're
done you know I mean they were so good
and then every time that they would
write a sketch and they would just
perform it and I tried to do it once in
a bumb anyway um but you know my thing
tables yeah yeah yeah I didn't my thing
was this i t I would tape
it so I would I would do like I would
record a sketch on my little cam Cod
that I bought and I would play like just
like like you know a Skeleton version of
what it might be so I tried different
things but anyway um yeah how was that
exper like I guess you interviewing me
but I'm a big Mad TV fan and so like
y'all you guys was doing stuff that was
so like extremely classic like that what
for real like it it was It was kind of
crazy it felt like it was weird because
it felt like you didn't didn't we didn't
care if it was like a like fitting with
SNL even just aiv it was his own [__]
thing like that that [__] was was it
just was it hilarious all the time no I
mean if you look at the magazine it was
a the magazine was a parody magazine
right right so it's like it was more
impression heavy you know what I mean
supposedly on Matt TV but I think once I
got on they were like uh
cuz he can't do
nothing I I literally can't do an imp
can you do an impression I could do
people I've done people like if I yell
at a guy can you do it I don't know
maybe like like Donald Trump can you do
him
yes that right there right is [__]
amazing no wor I I that that's it yeah
yeah if you did that okay I want to do a
facial thing I want to do a present if
you could get it okay
um Rich Nixon yeah I got it
too good guys are the same yeah pretty
good right pretty good you got it right
you never look so
Asian Asian rich Japanese girl or
Nixon Coachella yeah yeah yeah that was
bad um anyway I don't to play I'm I
don't know how to do them I don't know
how to do that's why it took us a a a
couple seconds like not him I knew it
was Richard Nicks here yeah yeah because
of this but what if he didn't say
president it wasn't it's it's literally
like cuz everything so as a person who
read M Magazines all the time and then
like mostly every impersonation of
Richard Nixon was that this it was that
yeah yeah yeah okay let let's see if I
can do an impression of of I going to do
an impression of an actor with just a
facial expression wait hold on
got it wait wait Michael J fox I was
thinking you're shaking a forget forget
the shake forget the shaking I'm
nervous wait forget the sh forget the
shaking I'm
nervous wait now I don't know who it is
anymore K
re I he did the KE keep crying keep
crying oh oh wait I got it um um
Christopher Walkin no no you know you're
talking to me yes who that uh uh daoo
yes see he knows it's the point it's
always it's like small thing your hand
acting is good your hand acting you're
great D yeah yeah so anyway do you do
one facial you do one facial see if I
can guess it you talking to me there
that was good that that was that was
good [__] incredible what you do
sometimes
that was a I'm legitimately good and you
know little r gets it but you you have
to do that sorry yeah yeah that's [__]
isn't there's a lot easier when because
you know you know I did a sketch series
Friends of the people with Germaine and
Lucas brothers and all those oh my those
guys are great and so like a lot of the
the when we did character stuff like
that they would just throw it at me and
I would just figure it out oh you could
figure it out I could do that pretty
like I'm not I don't like doing it on
the spot but I like the fact if I can
get into like we could get the look and
all this other